Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
SHANDI AND HER BOYFRIEND TRIED
TO DEAL WITH THE DISTANCE
BETWEEN THEM...
Shandi: I MISS MY BOYFRIEND.
BUT THEN I THOUGHT, I'M HERE.
I'M GONNA HAVE A GOOD TIME.
I DON'T CARE.
Tyra: PACK YOUR BAGS, Y'ALL.
YOU'RE GOING TO MILAN!
Women: (scream)
Tyra: THE GIRLS JET TO MILAN
AND GET TESTED RIGHT AWAY...
Woman: QUICKLY, PLEASE.
Man: AND DO YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCE-- NO, OKAY.
Woman: BYE.
Tyra: HARSH ITALIAN
CRITICISM RATTLED YOANNA...
THEY SAID YOU HAD TO WORK
ON YOUR BODY.
Yoanna: I WANT TO LEAVE.
Tyra: AND IN
THE LAST ELIMINATION...
Man: SHE WANTS TO KNOW
WHY YOU WALK LIKE THIS.
Camille: THIS IS
MY SIGNATURE WALK,
AND THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO
MAKE ME FAMOUS.
Tyra: IT WAS CAMILLE
WHO WAS SENT HOME.
ONLY FOUR GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
(alarm clock beeping)
Yoanna: WHOEVER SAID
MODELING'S EASY, IT IS NOT,
BUT THIS IS WHAT I WANT TO DO.
April: I'M TIRED,
BUT EVERY DAY
THAT PASSES BY HERE
IS ANOTHER DAY
THAT WE'RE CLOSER TO OUR DREAMS.
Shandi: EVERY DAY
IS MORE INTIMIDATING,
A LITTLE BIT MORE STRESSFUL.
Yoanna: "SENSUALITà,
BELLEZZA Y ELEGANZA.
FIND OUT WHAT THESE WORDS
MEAN TODAY.
BE READY TO LEAVE AT 12:15."
♪♪♪
Yoanna: ♪ WE WERE JUST GONE
CAMILLE LEFT HOME ♪♪
(laughing)
Mercedes: SO IT'S DOWN
TO FOUR.
YOANNA, APRIL, ME AND SHANDI.
WHERE THE HELL ARE MY BOOTS?
Yoanna: ♪ HAVE YOU SEEN ♪
♪ MY BOOTS? ♪♪
Mercedes: AT THE ELIMINATION
LAST NIGHT...
Tyra: MERCEDES,
CONGRATULATIONS.
Mercedes: TO BE HANDED
THIS PICTURE, I'M LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD.
I GOTTA STEP UP THE PACE."
April: ST. PATRICK,
PLEASE PROTECT ME.
Yoanna: YOU SHOULD PRAY
TO ST. ANTHONY, TOO. HE'S THE--
Mercedes: HE'S THE ONE
WHO FINDS THINGS, YEAH.
Yoanna: MY CHALLENGE
IS TO TONE MY TUMMY.
I HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN
KEEPING UP WITH IT
AS MUCH AS I SHOULD.
April: BUT WOULD IT BE
BAD LUCK TO PRAY TO HIM
BEFORE I'VE LOST SOMETHING?
I WANT THIS SO BAD.
I WANT TO BE A MODEL,
BUT I OVERANALYZE.
I KNOW THAT'S MY WEAKNESS.
IF I PUSHED YOU,
WILL YOU FALL OVER?
Shandi: I MISS BEING HOME
AND SEEING MY BOYFRIEND,
BUT THEN AT THE SAME TIME,
A HUGE PART OF ME WANTS
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LET'S GO, CHICAS.
THIS IS A REAL COMPETITION.
YOU KNOW, NO MATTER HOW MUCH
YOU LIKE THAT GIRL
STANDING NEXT TO YOU,
SHE'S TRYING TO BEAT YOU.
♪♪♪
Stephen: HELLO.
Yoanna: HELLO. I'M YOANNA.
Stephen: I'M
STEPHEN FAIRCHILD.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A KISS.
Yoanna: STEPHEN FAIRCHILD
IS AN INCREDIBLE DESIGNER.
WE GO INTO THE SHOWROOM,
AND THERE'S LUSCIOUS FABRICS.
Stephen: HELLO.
Mercedes: STEPHEN FAIRCHILD.
I'M LIKE, "OH, GOD, WAIT.
I THINK I KNOW THIS ONE."
INSIDE, HIS SHOWROOM
IS BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S MY STYLE IF I, YOU KNOW,
COULD DRESS HAUTE COUTURE
OR WHATEVER.
Stephen: WHAT I'M REALLY
GONNA DO IS TEACH YOU
ITALIAN FASHION,
THE SENSUALITY OF IT,
THE SEXUALITY OF IT.
IT'S GONNA BE DETERMINED
ON WHAT ARE YOUR GOOD ASSETS,
AND LET'S BRING THOSE OUT.
AND WHAT ARE YOUR BAD ASSETS,
LET'S TRY TO HIDE 'EM.
GO THROUGH THIS SHOWROOM,
PICK ONE OUTFIT
THAT YOU GUYS THINKS IS SEXY.
LET'S GO.
♪♪♪
Woman: IT'S REALLY TIGHT.
Stephen: ALL RIGHT, APRIL.
YEAH, SO LET'S OPEN UP
THE JACKET.
Mercedes: THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
Stephen: I THINK THE RAINCOAT
WAS COMPLETELY WRONG.
I THINK YOU HAVE
GREAT SHOULDERS.
I DO THINK YOU HAVE
VERY, VERY NICE LEGS,
AND I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE SHOWING YOUR LEGS.
SHANDI...
MAYBE YOU TEND TO PICK
TOO LARGE OF PANTS.
Shandi: I DON'T LIKE MY LEGS.
Stephen: YOU HAVE
MUCH BETTER LEGS
THAN YOU GIVE YOURSELF
CREDIT FOR.
MERCEDES, YOU'RE NEXT
ON THE LINEUP.
I THINK WE GOT
TO ELONGATE YOU.
I NEED TO LENGTHEN YOUR LEGS.
Yoanna: NOW IT'S MY TURN.
Stephen: YEAH.
TAKE YOUR JACKET OFF.
LET'S SEE YOUR BACK.
♪♪♪
Stephen: YOANNA
HAS ONE PROBLEM,
AND IT'S THE MIDRIFF.
THERE'S WAYS OF HIDING THAT,
BUT YOU GOTTA WORK AT TRYING
TO GET RID OF THAT ALSO.
April: OH, THAT WAS ROUGH,
MAN, BUT SHE'S GONNA HEAR IT.
Yoanna: IT'S TRUE
THAT I HAVE TO GET TONED UP,
BUT TYRA SAYS EVERY WOMAN
HAS SOME SORT OF FLAW.
MR. FAIRCHILD LET US KNOW
WHAT WE DID WRONG
OR WHAT WE DID RIGHT,
AND THEN HE WENT AHEAD
AND CORRECTED
ALL OF OUR MISTAKES.
♪♪♪
Stephen: I THINK YOU REFLECT TO
ME, NOT AMERICAN MODELS NOW.
THE WAY I'VE DRESSED YOU,
I THINK, IS MORE OF A REFLECTION
OF ITALIAN SENSUALITY.
Mercedes: NOW I KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN THEY SAY
ITALIAN SENSUALITY.
IT'S ABOUT CLOTHES FITTING
TO YOUR BODY PROPERLY
AND HAVING A LITTLE PIZZAZZ.
I LOVE IT.
I LOVE THIS STYLE.
Stephen: TOMORROW I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU EACH 200 EURO
TO GO TO THE FLEA MARKET.
WHAT I WANT YOU
TO TRY TO REMEMBER
IS DEPICT ITALIAN SENSUALITY.
THE WINNER IS GONNA COME SPEND
A GREAT, COOL EVENING WITH ME
AT MY VILLA.
THE WINNER IS GONNA HAVE
AN AMAZING NIGHT,
SO JUST REMEMBER THAT.
BYE.
♪♪♪
(telephone rings)
Yoanna: HELLO, YES,
IS ANDREA IN?
Mercedes: LAST WEEK WE MET
SOME GUYS ON THE VESPA
THAT TOOK US AROUND MILAN.
Yoanna: THIS EVENING
YOU'RE GONNA BE JOINING US
AT THE MILAN APARTMENT.
April: YOANNA CALLS
THE REALLY CUTE ONE,
AND HE SAYS HE'LL COME
AND BRING SOME FRIENDS.
Mercedes: I'VE BEEN
SO TESTOSTERONE DEPRIVED.
IT'S SO NOT FAIR.
Yoanna: OKAY, WONDERFUL.
I'M NOT DATING ANYONE RIGHT NOW.
SO I DEFINITELY WANT
TO GET SOME SMOOCHES ON.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
Mercedes: EVERYBODY KNOWS
I'M SINGLE.
I WANT TO MEET SOME GUYS
TO HAVE A GOOD TIME.
Shandi: I MISS MY BOYFRIEND.
I DO.
I REALLY WISH HE COULD HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS WITH ME.
I HAVE NO DOUBTS IN MY MIND
THAT I WANT TO BE WITH HIM.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: STUPIDO!
Mercedes: OH,
THAT'S PRETTY, SHANDI.
♪♪♪
(rings doorbell)
Yoanna: I'LL GO.
HI, HOW ARE YOU?
BUONA SERA.
April: HI.
Mercedes: OH,
YOU BROUGHT US FOOD!
Man: LET'S HAVE A TOAST
TO THIS WONDERFUL COMPANY.
TO YOU!
Mercedes: TO LIFE.
April: THEY'RE
VERY GOOD-LOOKING.
AND THE GREAT THING
ABOUT ITALIAN MEN,
YOU CAN SHOP WITH THEM.
YOU CAN SLEEP WITH THEM, TOO.
BUT OF COURSE, I'M TAKEN, SO...
Orlando: IT'S ITALIAN WINE.
Mercedes: ITALIAN WINE.
I'M LIKE, OKAY, I SEE
A COUPLE CUTIES IN THE CROWD.
I START DRINKING A LITTLE VINO.
AND I START, YOU KNOW,
GETTING IN A GOOD MOOD.
DO YOU KNOW BRITNEY SPEARS?
Niccolo: YEAH, YEAH,
WE ARE ITALIAN.
WE DON'T LIVE
ON A DESERT ISLAND.
Shandi: IT FEELS GOOD
JUST TO HANG OUT AND JUST CHILL
AT THE HOUSE,
BUT MY BOYFRIEND'S NOT HERE.
WHAT AM I GONNA DO?
Jean Luc: DO YOU WANT
ANY MORE WINE?
Yoanna: SHANDI. SHANDI.
YOU'RE A VERY PASSIONATE PERSON.
All: (laughing)
Yoanna: WHEN I SAW NICCOLO,
I COULD TELL
THERE WAS SOMETHING SPECIAL
ABOUT HIM.
HE SEEMED REALLY SWEET
AND SINCERE OUT OF THE GUYS.
DO YOU HAVE AN MP3 PLAYER?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THOSE ARE?
Niccolo: NOT REALLY.
BUT THANK YOU, THOUGH.
Yoanna: I HAVE ONE.
YOU WANT TO SEE ONE?
THESE HERE--DISCS--
HAVE YOU SEEN THEM BEFORE?
YOUR DADDY BUYS THEM FOR YOU?
Niccolo: NO, HE DOESN'T.
(laughs)
I LIKE YOUR STYLE SO MUCH.
Yoanna: WE WENT INTO MY ROOM,
AND WE STARTED TALKING
ABOUT OUR INTEREST IN MUSIC.
IT'S OKAY.
(laughs)
EASY.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT WAS JUST, SOMETHING CLICKED.
Shandi: YOANNA
WAS MAKING OUT.
SHH!
April: (laughs)
Yoanna: NICCOLO HAS WONDERFUL
ASSETS, IN THE BANK
AS WELL AS BEHIND.
All: (laughing)
Shandi: WE'RE GOING IN THE TUB.
Yoanna: ALL RIGHT!
Shandi: WE'RE GONNA GET
IN THE TUB!
OH, MERCEDES!
All: (laughing and screaming)
Mercedes: APRIL! APRIL!
APRIL!
April: I'M HIDING,
LIKE AROUND A CORNER
AS I HEAR SCREAMS OF,
"APRIL, WHERE'S APRIL?"
I MEAN, THEN I JUST DECIDE,
LIKE, I CAN'T HIDE FOREVER.
All: (laughing and screaming)
April: THESE GIRLS, SELF
INCLUDED, HAVE BEEN LIKE
MONKEYS IN A CAGE.
AND YOU DROP BIG BANANAS INSIDE,
OF COURSE THEY'RE GONNA TEAR
THE PEELS OFF.
SHANDI'S IN THE HOT TUB
WITH ONE OF THE OTHER GUYS,
AND HE'S SITTING BEHIND HER
WITH HIS ARMS AROUND HER,
SO THEY HAVEN'T KISSED YET,
BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT
THEY'RE GONNA HOOK UP PROBABLY.
Shandi: I THINK, LIKE,
A PART OF ME JUST, LIKE,
GOT CAUGHT UP IN EVERYTHING,
LIKE, JUST CAUGHT UP IN,
LIKE, THE SEXUAL TENSION.
HAVING REALLY GOOD-LOOKING GUYS
COME OVER, AND THEN
ALL GETTING IN THE JACUZZI.
April: DING!
HOLD ON A SECOND, SHANDI.
YOU'VE GOT A BOYFRIEND.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: SO WE'RE IN
THE JACUZZI,
AND I KNOW
SHANDI HAS A BOYFRIEND.
SHANDI'S BEEN UNDER
A LOT OF STRESS,
AND SHE'S JUST HAVING FUN.
Shandi: WHOO!
Yoanna: I GUESS I JUST AM
LETTING SHANDI DO HER OWN THING.
Shandi: I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
Yoanna: I'M NOT REALLY
THINKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
THAT SHE HAS A BOYFRIEND,
BUT I WAS KIND OF LIKE,
"OH, WHY IS SHE GOING THIS FAR?"
(bell tolling)
Man: CIAO.
Yoanna: OKAY.
Shandi: (crying)
I JUST COULDN'T CONTROL MYSELF.
LIKE, I REALLY COULDN'T.
HE WAS THERE,
AND I HAD ALL THIS TENSION,
AND I LET IT GO.
I JUST LET IT HAPPEN.
(crying)
April: IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
FACT FOR SHANDI,
SHE'S FEELING EXTREME GUILT
ABOUT THE FACT THAT SHE'S
CHEATED ON HER BOYFRIEND ERIC.
Shandi: I WANT TO DIE.
Yoanna: IT'S OVER.
IT'S OVER.
YOU'RE NOT A BAD PERSON.
Shandi: BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT! NO.
Yoanna: SWEETHEART,
COME HERE.
IT'S OVER.
DON'T LET THIS
TAKE AWAY YOUR SPIRIT.
IT'S GONNA BREAK YOUR SPIRIT.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: SHANDI, WE GOTTA GO.
April: NOW THAT THE BLOOD
IS STARTING TO RETURN
TO THE BRAIN, AND THE WINE
IS STARTING TO DRAIN,
SHE'S REALIZING
THAT WHAT SHE DID
WAS EXTREMELY HURTFUL.
Shandi: AFTER EVERYTHING,
I JUST WANNA GO HOME.
April: DID YOU GET
TO FALL ASLEEP LAST NIGHT?
Shandi: NO ONE, LIKE, TRIED
TO PULL ME ASIDE AND SAY, LIKE,
"HEY, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?"
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I, LIKE, DON'T EXPECT THEM TO
BECAUSE I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF MYSELF.
I DID THIS.
IT IS MY FAULT. IT'S ALL
MY FAULT.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: OUR CHALLENGE IS
TO GO TO THE FLEA MARKET
WITH $200 IN OUR POCKET
AND ONLY ONE HOUR TO PICK OUT
A STYLE THAT REPRESENTS
ITALIAN SENSUALITY.
April: AT THE SAME TIME,
PICKING UP ON THE FEEDBACK
STEPHEN FAIRCHILD
GAVE EACH ONE OF US.
Yoanna: I'VE ONLY WON
ONE CHALLENGE SO FAR.
AND IT'S LIKE I HAD TO GET
THIS OTHER CHALLENGE.
I WANTED TO HAVE A GREAT NIGHT
AT THAT VILLA.
Mercedes: I REALLY WANTED
TO GO FOR THE PANTS
'CAUSE I REALLY WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT HE KNOWS THAT
I TOOK IN ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT HE GAVE ME.
Woman: GRAZIE. CIAO, BELLA.
Mercedes: GRAZIE. CIAO.
April: I'M JUST THINKING,
SHOW LEG, BE SEXY.
WHITE ON TOP
AND BLACK ON BOTTOM
AND DON'T RUN OVER
ANYONE'S TOES.
Yoanna: (speaks Italian)
THE JACKET WAS KEY,
BECAUSE HE HAD TOLD ME
ABOUT MY SHOULDERS,
AND I WANTED TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT WOULD FIT.
OH, WHERE DID IT GO?
THIS IS IT, RIGHT? YEAH.
Man: (speaking Italian)
Yoanna: GRAZIE.
Shandi: I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHERE I'M GONNA START.
MY MIND IS PRETTY MUCH
ALL TANGLED UP
WITH THE PREVIOUS NIGHT.
I THINK IT'S TOO BIG.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THOUGH.
IT'S TOO BIG.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: AFTER
THE FLEA MARKET, WE FIND OUT
WE'RE GOING TO A PLACE
CALLED LAKE COMO.
LAKE COMO IS ABOUT 30
TO 45 MINUTES OUTSIDE OF MILAN.
Mercedes: I WAS TRYING
TO SPEAK IN ITALIAN
WHILE BARTERING--
BARGAINING SO BAD.
I WAS LIKE,
"PANTALONI STRETCHY."
Women: (laughing)
April: SHANDI'S FEELING DOWN
ON HERSELF.
GIRLS CHEAT.
IT HAPPENS.
Yoanna: (Italian accent)
AMERICAN GIRL, I KISS YOU, TOO,
ITALIAN BOY.
Shandi: I FINALLY HAVE
SOMEONE THAT'S, LIKE,
PROUD OF ME FOR ONCE.
AND THEN LOOK WHAT I GO AND DO,
YOU KNOW?
AND THAT MAKES ME THINK, LIKE,
IS THIS HOW I'M ALWAYS GONNA BE?
LIKE, ONCE I FIND SOMEONE,
AM I GONNA MESS IT UP?
Mercedes: OH,
YOU GOTTA MAKE A WISH
WHEN WE GO UNDER THE TUNNEL,
AND YOU HAVE TO
HOLD YOUR BREATH.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: BEAUTIFUL!
OH, MY GOSH!
WE'RE DRIVING UP THE DRIVEWAY
OF MR. FAIRCHILD'S VILLA.
IT'S LIKE, WOW.
THIS TRIP IS GETTING BETTER
AND BETTER.
HOW ARE YOU?
Stephen: GOOD. AND YOU?
Yoanna: GOOD.
Stephen: I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO MY WIFE.
♪♪♪
Stephen: THIS IS THE NICEST
BEDROOM IN THE HOUSE,
BECAUSE IT HAS THE VIEW.
Yoanna: OH,
IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
Stephen: THE WINNER
OF THE CHALLENGE
WILL STAY IN THIS ROOM.
AND THE LOSERS WILL STAY
IN THIS ROOM.
WELCOME TO OUR HOUSE.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO NOW
IS A CHALLENGE.
I WANNA PUT THE THINGS
THAT YOU BOUGHT
ON EACH ONE OF YOU.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
♪♪♪
Shandi: IT IS KINDA LIKE A JOB.
HE GAVE ME SOMETHING TO PUT IN,
LIKE, THE FOREGROUND.
AND I THINK THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
HELPED ME FOCUS WAS THAT, LIKE,
OH, I NEED TO DO THIS.
I NEED TO FIND THIS
INSTEAD OF THINKING,
"OH, WHAT DID I JUST DO
THE OTHER DAY?"
Stephen: SO YOU GUYS
HAVE BEEN WORKING.
WE'LL START WITH YOU, APRIL.
Stephen: SO WHY DID YOU PICK
WHAT YOU HAVE?
April: I PICKED
THE BOTTOM PART BECAUSE I WANTED
TO SHOW OFF MY LEGS.
Stephen: YOANNA.
DO YOU THINK YOU ARE BRINGING
OUT YOUR BETTER ATTRIBUTES
AND HIDING YOUR...
Yoanna: YES,
BUT I DON'T THINK I DID
100% AS GOOD AS I SHOULD.
Stephen: MERCEDES.
Mercedes: I WAS LOOKING
FOR PANTS TO ELONGATE MY LEGS
LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT.
Stephen: SHANDI.
Shandi: I PICKED A SKIRT
'CAUSE I WANTED TO SHOW MY LEGS,
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW, YOU MENTIONED
THAT THAT WAS A GOOD ASSET
FOR ME.
Stephen: AND CAN YOU WALK
FOR ME, TOO, PLEASE?
♪♪♪
Stephen: I REALLY THINK IT'S
GREAT SHE'S SHOWING HER LEGS.
MERCEDES, YOU HAVE
SUCH GREAT SHOULDERS,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU'RE COVERING
YOUR SHOULDERS UP AGAIN.
YOANNA, I DO LIKE THE PROPORTION
OF THE JACKET THAT YOU PICKED.
IT'S THE PANTS THAT ARE THROWING
IT ALL OFF-KILTER.
APRIL, YOU SHOWED THE PERFECT
PART OF SKIN.
WHAT I DON'T LIKE IS THAT
I FIND THAT THE MINISKIRT
THAT YOU PICKED,
IT'S TOO MUCH CONFLICTING
WITH THE SCARF.
WELL, I'M GONNA PICK A WINNER
RIGHT NOW.
AND I'M GONNA PICK SHANDI.
Shandi: WHAT?
I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT I ACTUALLY WON THIS ONE
BECAUSE MY MIND
IS SOMEWHERE ELSE.
Yoanna: I'M THINKING,
"OH, JEEZ, LOUISE!
SHANDI'S WON ANOTHER SOMETHING."
I DON'T KNOW.
I WAS FEELING ALL DISAPPOINTED,
LIKE, I THOUGHT MAYBE I WOULD
HAVE NAILED THE STYLE PART.
Stephen: THE REASON WHY
I PICKED SHANDI RIGHT AWAY
IS BECAUSE I THINK SHE REALLY
LISTENED TO ME YESTERDAY.
I WANT YOU TO PICK SOMEBODY
WHO'S GONNA JOIN YOU
THIS EVENING TO SPEND
IN THE WINNER'S SUITE.
Shandi: YOANNA.
Stephen: OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
Shandi: ALL THESE GIRLS
HELPED ME OUT A LOT, BUT I FEEL
THE CLOSEST TO YOANNA.
Stephen: AT 7:00, I WOULD
LIKE TO ALL MEET DOWNSTAIRS
FOR DINNER WITH GOOD,
ITALIAN FRIENDS OF MINE.
♪♪♪
Stephen: ARE YOU HUNGRY?
Women: OH, YEAH!
Stephen: OKAY.
SHANDI, YOANNA,
I'M GONNA HAVE YOU SIT HERE.
APRIL AND MERCEDES,
BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENGE,
I'M GONNA HAVE YOU BOTH
SIT OVER HERE.
Mercedes: OH,
IT'S GONNA BE SO INTIMATE.
TALK ABOUT STATUS DEMOTE.
Stephen: BUON APPETITO.
Mercedes: AH, GRAZIE.
Yoanna: SHANDI AND I HAVE
THE "PRIVILEGED" TABLE.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WORK
FOR VALENTINO AND CALVIN KLEIN.
Stephen: TO MODELING!
Woman: TO MODELING!
April: MERCEDES AND I
ARE DEFINITELY AT A DISADVANTAGE
AT OUR TABLE.
Mercedes: I'M SORRY.
I HAVE, LIKE, A BUG, IN MY EYE
OR SOMETHING.
IT SUCKS! IT SUCKS SO HARD!
Woman: WHO'S YOUR MUSE?
Yoanna: KATE MOSS.
Woman: MY FAVORITE MODEL
IS CHRISTY TURLINGTON.
Mercedes: OOH!
Stephen: WHAT'S GOING ON?
THERE'S WHAT?
THERE'S A BUG?
Mercedes: IT'S GONE.
ALL GONE.
Woman #2: MINE WOULD BE
KATE MOSS.
Stephen: KATE MOSS, TOO.
Woman #2: YEAH, YEAH.
Stephen: AND WHAT...
Shandi: HMM...
Stephen: (laughs)
Yoanna: I THINK SHANDI
BEING STRESSED ABOUT HER
SITUATION WITH HER BOYFRIEND
HAS SUCKED A LOT OF HER ENERGY.
Shandi: DINNER
WAS REALLY HARD.
I HAVE TO TALK TO ERIC
ON THE PHONE LATER TONIGHT.
Woman #2: GOOD LUCK.
Yoanna: BYE.
Woman: NICE TO MEET YOU.
Stephen: SHANDI,
I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR YOU.
HERE IT IS FOR YOU.
Shandi: "YOU'VE GOTTEN
TO KNOW EACH OTHER VERY WELL.
TOMORROW YOU'LL GET TO KNOW
EACH OTHER EVEN BETTER.
BE READY TO LEAVE
AT 7:30 A.M."
DO YOU THINK SHE KNOWS
WHAT WENT ON LAST NIGHT,
AND THAT'S WHY SHE WROTE,
"YOU'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW
EACH OTHER VERY WELL"?
April: TYRA KNOWS EVERYTHING.
(cell phone buttons beeping)
Shandi: THIS IS PROBABLY, LIKE,
THE MOST OVERWHELMING,
LIKE, STRESSFUL THING I'VE EVER,
EVER HAD TO DO.
OH, GOD.
IN, LIKE,
THE NEXT MINUTE OR SO,
I COULD COMPLETELY LOSE,
LIKE, EVERYTHING.
Eric: Hey.
Shandi: HI.
Eric: How you doing?
Shandi: NOT SO GOOD.
Eric: What's wrong?
Shandi: I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO START THIS.
Eric: What did you do?
Shandi: I JUST WANNA LET
MY BOYFRIEND KNOW WHAT HAPPENED,
BUT I'M SO SCARED.
(Shandi crying)
Eric: Just please tell me what
you did.
Just tell me.
Shandi: JUST THINK
OF THE WORST POSSIBLE THING
I COULD DO.
Eric: You had sex?!
Shandi: YEAH.
Eric: Oh, my God, Honey!
Oh, my God!
Eric: Just please tell me
what you did.
Shandi: OKAY.
Eric: Just tell me.
Shandi: JUST THINK
OF THE WORST POSSIBLE THING
I COULD DO.
Eric: You had sex?!
Shandi: YEAH.
I DON'T EXPECT HIM
TO WANT TO CONTINUE, LIKE,
TO WANNA WORK IT OUT.
I DON'T THINK
HE'S GONNA BE WILLING.
Eric: Why'd you do it?
Shandi: I DON'T KNOW.
Eric: Were you that lonely?
Shandi: (crying)
Eric: Did it happen last night?
Shandi: YEAH.
Eric: You've changed.
You're not Shandi.
To cheat on someone you've known
for four years,
I never thought
you could do that.
Shandi: (crying) I DIDN'T
THINK SO, EITHER.
Eric: I can't be with someone
that cheated on me.
Shandi: OH, GOD.
Eric: What do you
want me to do?!
What can I say to this?
How can I hug you?
Shandi: (crying)
Eric: This is so messed up.
Didn't you think back to
everything we've been through?
Did you think about how we
wanted to be together forever?
Then you throw it away.
You stupid bitch!
Shandi: (crying)
Eric: Why did you do this?
(crying)
What were you thinking?!
I'm hanging up.
(click)
Shandi: I JUST WANNA SEE ERIC
AND JUST, LIKE,
LOOK HIM IN THE EYE
AND JUST, LIKE, LET HIM KNOW,
YOU KNOW, THAT I CARE ABOUT HIM.
(crying)
♪♪♪
Jay: BUONGIORNO, PRINCIPESSE.
IT ONLY MAKES SENSE THAT WE USE
THIS BEAUTIFUL BACKDROP
FOR OUR PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA DIVIDE YOU
INTO TWO TEAMS,
AND ACTUALLY, YOU'RE STANDING
IN YOUR PAIRS RIGHT NOW.
IT'S GONNA BE APRIL
AND MERCEDES TOGETHER,
YOANNA AND SHANDI TOGETHER,
AND THIS IS
NO PIECE OF CAKE, GIRLS.
IT'S DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
OUTSHINE THE OTHER.
YOU HAVE TWO PHOTOGRAPHERS
TODAY--
ALEX MARTINENGO
AND AMILCARE INCALZA.
THEY'LL BE SHOOTING YOU FROM TWO
TOTALLY DIFFERENT ANGLES,
AND OF COURSE,
LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
WE HAVE THE FABULOUS NOLé MARIN
HERE FROM NEW YORK CITY,
WHO IS GOING TO STYLE
YOU GIRLS, OKAY?
(Italian accent)
WE'RE GOING TO DO VERY LONG
ITALIAN STRAIGHT WEAVES
ON ALL OF YOU GIRLS.
Yoanna: OH, YEAH!
♪♪♪
Jay: ALL RIGHT,
SO LET'S GO SEE NOLé.
Nolé: WELCOME, JAY.
Jay: IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH A LOT OF ITALIAN ADS,
LIKE VERSACE OR DOLCE & GABBANA,
THEIR ADS CAN OFTEN USE
TWO WOMEN TOGETHER,
AND THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING
VERY KIND OF SEXY AND SENSUAL.
Nolé: PASSION.
Jay: YOU KNOW, TO CREATE THAT
ITALIAN FASHION MAGAZINE STYLE,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE NUDE.
(sound of screeching car brakes)
Yoanna: I THOUGHT WE WERE GONNA
BE HAVING ACCESSORIES,
BUT SURPRISE, SURPRISE.
THE ONLY ACCESSORY WAS
OUR HAIR.
Jay: SO WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE WEARING ARE SHOES
AND ACCESSORIES.
April: YES.
Nolé: THAT'S IT.
Jay: THAT'S IT.
April: I LOVE IT.
Mercedes: WOW.
April: I THINK IT'S AWESOME.
I'D RATHER POSE NUDE
THAN WITH CLOTHING ON.
Jay: LOOK AT MERCEDES.
SHE'S LIKE, OKAY...
April: SHE'LL LOVE IT.
Mercedes: MODELING IS ART,
BUT I WASN'T READY
FOR THIS TYPE OF ART,
ESPECIALLY WITH APRIL.
Yoanna: WE'RE NOT NERVOUS
ABOUT POSING WITH EACH OTHER
'CAUSE WE'RE CONFIDENT
IN OUR SEXUALITY.
April: THIS COULD BE
KINDA COOL
IF WE HAVE SOME KIND OF WAY
TO MAKE IT SEXY.
WE MIGHT NOT BE
AS HIGH FASHION AS THEM,
BUT WHEN I THINK
OF THE BOYS BACK HOME,
WHO THEY'D RATHER SEE NAKED
ON TOP OF EACH OTHER,
I HAVE A FEELING IT MIGHT BE US.
Jay: ARE YOU READY?
Man: YES, WE ARE READY.
Jay: READY TO GO?
REMEMBER SENSUAL, NOT SLEAZY.
YOU GUYS WILL HAVE TO
GET CLOSER.
YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
Alex: BEAUTIFUL. LIKE THAT.
GORGEOUS.
Jay: GREAT, YOANNA.
THAT'S PERFECT.
KEEP WITH THAT.
OH, YEAH, YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
Man: SI!
(shutter clicks)
Alex: AND BOTH EYES ON ME
RIGHT NOW.
Yoanna: I NEED
TO HIDE CERTAIN THINGS,
SO I JUST HAVE TO
WORK AROUND SHANDI
AND KIND OF, LIKE,
SCULPT MY BODY INTO HER BODY.
Jay: THAT'S GOOD, YOANNA,
FOR A POSE.
YOANNA IS DEFINITELY
PAYING ATTENTION.
(shutter clicks)
Jay: OH, SHANDI, THAT LEG HAS
TO MOVE FORWARD.
DON'T THINK ABOUT POSING NOW.
JUST DO.
AND JUST TURN YOUR FACE OUT
TO THE CAMERA.
Shandi: TALKING
WITH MY BOYFRIEND LAST NIGHT
ON THE PHONE MADE ME MENTALLY
AND, LIKE, PHYSICALLY EXHAUSTED.
I'M TRYING TO DEAL WITH IT
AND JUST TRY AND STAY FOCUSED.
Jay: SHANDI, YOUR HEAD'S UP
A LITTLE TOO HIGH.
SHANDI IS REALLY
NOT PAYING ATTENTION.
JUST DON'T MAKE US LOOK UP
YOUR NOSE.
Nolé: THE VERY FIRST TIME
I WORKED WITH SHANDI,
SHE WAS LIKE A BOILED CHICKEN
IN A FISH TANK.
TODAY, SHE COMPLETELY DROWNED.
April: YOU'RE
A PASSIVE FEMALE DOE.
I'M THE BUCK.
THIS PHOTO SHOOT IS GOING TO
DETERMINE WHO IS GOING HOME.
I DON'T WANT THAT TO BE ME,
AND I DON'T WANT IT
TO BE MERCEDES.
I'M SURE THAT'S ANIMAL INSTINCT.
Mercedes: I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH POSING WITH APRIL.
Nolé: YOU READY?
April: YEAH.
Nolé: LET'S GO.
(shutter clicking)
Amilcare: YES, BELLA. YOU ARE,
LIKE, TOTALLY TOGETHER.
NO, TOO MUCH POSE, THIS.
NATURALE.
Jay: ALWAYS CHEAT YOUR FACES
A LITTLE,
BUT LOOK AT EACH OTHER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
Mercedes: YEAH.
April: HERE. I'M GONNA PUT
MY CHIN ON YOUR HEAD, BABY.
Jay: APRIL OVER-DIRECTED
EACH PHOTOGRAPH,
TRYING TO ART DIRECT.
APRIL IS ALMOST TRYING
TO TAKE OVER MY JOB.
April: CAN WE, LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW, MOVE THE FLOOR
OR SOMETHING?
I DON'T KNOW.
COME ON, OKAY?
Jay: MERCEDES SEEMED
A LITTLE LOST,
AND SHE ACTUALLY ALLOWED APRIL
TO BOSS HER AROUND THE SHOOT.
April: I WAS JUST TRYING
TO HELP.
Alex: RELAX. JUST RELAX.
Mercedes: I'M LIKE,
WHEN IS THIS GONNA BE OVER?
Jay: LAST FRAME.
Alex: YES, BEAUTIFUL.
(shutter clicks)
Jay: GREAT, GIRLS.
Man: LADIES...
Mercedes: FINALLY,
IT WAS OVER.
♪♪♪
Tyra: AAH!
HOW ARE YOU?
April: HI.
Tyra: BUONA SERA.
CIAO, BELLA.
Yoanna: AFTER
OUR BIG PHOTO SHOOT, WE MEET UP
WITH TYRA FOR SOME CAPPUCCINOS
AT A REALLY CUTE CAFé.
Tyra: WELL, I HAD TO DO
A GIRL-ON-GIRL SHOOT IN MILANO,
LIKE WHAT YOU GUYS DID.
EVERY SHOOT THAT YOU GUYS DO,
I'VE DONE.
Yoanna: WITH TYRA BANKS,
WHAT DID WE NOT TALK ABOUT
THAT EVENING?
April: I'LL TELL YOU WHAT,
TYRA.
YOU KNOW HOW YOU GUYS THINK
I'M TENSE IN THAT ROOM,
THAT'S SEXUAL TENSION.
Tyra: YOU'RE TENSE
BECAUSE YOU WANT NIGEL.
April: YES.
Yoanna: AHH!
All: (laughing)
Tyra: YOU LIKE NIGEL?
YOU GUYS WANT
ANY ADVICE FOR...
I'M VERY TECHNICAL,
LIKE A PHYSICIAN.
Tyra: I'VE NEVER CHEATED
ON A BOYFRIEND.
Shandi: OR HAVE ANYONE CHEAT
ON YOU?
Tyra: I'VE NEVER--
OH, GOSH, YEAH.
I HAD ONE GUY THAT CHEATED ON ME
IN MILANO.
HE WAS A MALE MODEL, CHILD.
AND THAT JUST HURT ME SO MUCH,
BUT NOW I ALWAYS TELL MY MAN,
LIKE, DON'T CHEAT.
FLIRT SO MUCH WITH A GIRL,
AND THEN COME HOME AND DO ME.
Women: (laughing)
Tyra: DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, MISS SHANDI?
Shandi: MM-HMM. THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE TEARING UP OR SOMETHING.
YEAH, IS SHE OKAY?
DID YOUR BOYFRIEND CHEAT ON YOU?
YOU CHEATED ON HIM?
REALLY?
EVERYBODY'S MESSED UP, SHANDI.
Shandi: I KNOW.
Tyra: I'M NOT JUDGING YOU,
BUT I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGHT AGAINST OUR CARNAL DESIRES
AND SOMETIMES THEY SLIP,
BUT I DON'T SEE IT
AS THE END OF THE WORLD.
I UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE
DO BECOME ATTRACTED
TO OTHER PEOPLE,
YOU KNOW, IN THE MOMENT.
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT
YOUR RELATIONSHIP AND HOW OPEN
YOUR RELATIONSHIP IS
AND HOW HONEST YOU CAN BE
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
DID YOU TELL HIM?
YOU DID TELL HIM.
Shandi: YEP.
Tyra: DID HE FORGIVE YOU?
Shandi: FOR ABOUT
TWO MINUTES, IT WAS JUST HIM
CRYING AND SAYING, "OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD! OH, MY GOD!"
THEN IT GOES TO, "I CAN'T BE
WITH SOMEONE THAT CHEATED ON ME.
I HATE YOU, YOU STUPID BITCH.
HOW COULD YOU DO THAT?"
Tyra: THAT'S JUST NORMAL.
OH, HE LOVES YOU.
Shandi: YOU KNOW THAT WHEN
TYRA'S TELLING YOU SOMETHING,
THAT IT'S TRULY COMING
FROM, LIKE, HER HEART.
I'M JUST GONNA HAVE TO FACE IT
AND THEN WHATEVER HAPPENS,
HAPPENS, AND I'M, YOU KNOW,
I'VE CHANGED SO MUCH.
Tyra: I THINK
YOU'LL BE OKAY, THOUGH.
HOW HAVE YOU CHANGED?
April: I FEEL LIKE
THE PAST YEAR
I WORKED IN BUSINESS,
I WAS, LIKE, CONDITIONED--
EMOTIONS, LEAVE 'EM AT THE DOOR.
AND FOR SOME REASON,
COMING TO EUROPE REMINDED ME
OF THAT TIME IN MY LIFE
WHEN I WASN'T LIKE THAT.
Tyra: THAT'S GOOD, THOUGH.
April: YEAH, IT'S HELPING ME.
Mercedes: AS FAR AS MODELING,
I THOUGHT MODELING
WAS A LOT EASIER.
I WAS SO WRONG, YOU KNOW?
Shandi: WE WERE ALL WRONG.
Mercedes: IT'S LIKE
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT IT
AS A BUSINESS,
AS HOW YOU STYLE YOURSELF,
HOW YOUR PERSONALITY IS,
AND IT'S LIKE,
I NEVER KNEW THAT.
Tyra: HAVE YOU CHANGED,
BEING IN FASHION INSTEAD
OF JUST WORSHIPPING IT?
Yoanna: THERE'S SO MUCH
I'VE LEARNED THAT I NEVER KNEW.
IT'S JUST SEEMED LIKE,
OKAY, I FOUND MY NICHE.
THIS IS ALWAYS WHERE
I'VE MEANT TO BE.
LIKE, I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW.
IT JUST KINDA FEELS LIKE HOME.
WELL, CAN WE JUST SAY
SOMETHING NOW?
AND I THINK WE'VE ALL FELT THIS.
THAT IF IT'S OUR TURN
TO GO HOME TOMORROW,
JUST TO SAY, ACTUALLY,
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'VE BLESSED US WITH
ON THIS TRIP.
I MEAN, IT'S A DREAM.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
Mercedes: IT IS A DREAM.
♪♪♪
April: OH, GOOD JOB.
Yoanna: OH,
WE GOT TYRA MAIL, YOU GUYS.
April: THE TYRA MAIL SAID
TOMORROW IS ANOTHER ELIMINATION,
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
Mercedes: ARE YOU
GETTIN' READY TO USE THE PHONE?
(cell phone buttons beeping)
Eric: When are you coming home?
Shandi: SOON.
Eric: Do you want to stay
in this relationship?
Shandi: YES.
Eric: Okay, I just wanted
to hear that.
Shandi: MY BOYFRIEND'S BEEN
WITH ME BEFORE ALL THIS
EVEN STARTED,
SO I HAVE NO DOUBTS IN MY MIND
THAT I STILL WANT
TO BE WITH HIM.
Eric: You still have to
bust your ass to try
and get a contract, okay?
Shandi: OKAY.
I KNOW ELIMINATION
IS TOMORROW, BUT I JUST DON'T
FEEL LIKE I HAVE THE STRENGTH
TO DO THIS.
I ALMOST, LIKE, DON'T EVEN WANT
TO TRY.
Eric: I'm mad at you,
but it's subsiding, okay?
Shandi: I KNOW.
Eric: I don't want you
to give up, okay?
Shandi: OKAY.
Eric: Just be good.
Shandi: I MISS YOU.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
Women: HELLO.
Tyra: NOW IT IS TIME
TO MAKE OUR NINTH CUT
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AMONG THE PRIZES WILL BE
A CONTRACT
WITH THE MODELING AGENCY
THAT I SO HAPPEN TO BE WITH--
IMG MODELS--
AND A FASHION SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
AND NOW LET ME INTRODUCE
OUR JUDGES.
NOW EVERYBODY KNOWS, FIRST...
(Jamaican accent)
IT'S MISS JANICE DICKINSON, YES.
Janice: (Jamaican accent)
BUT THANK YOU, MISS TYRA.
YOU SAY THE BEST THINGS ABOUT
THE WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODEL.
Tyra: (normal voice)
YEAH, SHE SAID IT HERSELF.
AND NEXT WE HAVE ERIC NICHOLSON.
ERIC IS
THE SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
OF "JANE" MAGAZINE.
WE ALSO HAVE NIGEL BARKER,
A VERY SEXY
AND NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
OVER HERE
WE SEE OUR GUEST JUDGE--
STEPHEN FAIRCHILD,
WHO IS A VERY RENOWNED
MILAN-BASED FASHION DESIGNER.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND STEPHEN IS GONNA PUT YOU
TO THE TEST.
Stephen: WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO
IS PRETEND THAT YOU JUST
GOT OFF A PLANE IN ITALY.
ALL YOU HAVE
IS THE PANTS YOU'RE WEARING,
SOME SHOES AND A T-SHIRT.
FROM THE PLANE, IMMEDIATELY,
YOU'RE GONNA GO
TO A WICKED PARTY.
ALONG WITH THE T-SHIRTS,
YOU HAVE A PAIR OF SCISSORS,
RIBBON, SAFETY PINS
AND YOU GOT SOME PENS.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
WITH THE T-SHIRT.
THE OBJECTIVE IS TO LOOK SEXY.
Tyra: ARE YOU READY?
YOU SET?
GO!
♪♪♪
Judges: (applauding)
Stephen: WELL DONE.
Tyra: THE BLUE GIRLS!
SO, SHANDI, TELL US
ABOUT YOUR OUTFIT.
Shandi: SINCE I'M NOT
SHOWING LEGS, I WANTED TO SHOW
A LITTLE BIT OF SKIN,
AND SO THAT'S WHY I DID
THE OFF-THE-SHOULDER,
SO YOU COULD SEE
A LITTLE BIT OF THE BACK
AND A LITTLE BIT OF THE FRONT.
Tyra: I FEEL
LIKE YOU COULD TOTALLY WALK
DOWN THE RED CARPET WITH THAT,
AND THE PAPARAZZI
WOULD BE YELLING,
"SHANDI, WHO DID YOUR SHIRT?"
Nigel: SHANDI, I THINK
YOU ARE REALLY INSPIRATIONAL,
AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE FASHION INDUSTRY
TO HAVE A MUSE, AND YOU ARE
DEFINITELY BECOMING THAT FOR ME.
Janice: SHANDI,
I NEVER REALIZED WHAT
LOVELY SHOULDERS YOU DO HAVE,
SO THAT WAS AN EXCELLENT CHOICE
TO WHACK IT UP.
Stephen: I THINK
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF YOU.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
YOANNA'S NEXT.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR OUTFIT.
Yoanna: WELL, I WANTED
TO KEEP IT SIMPLE AND CLASSIC.
I THOUGHT THE BOW
KIND OF SET IT OFF.
Janice: YOANNA, I THINK
IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
LIKE A STRAIGHTJACKET.
Nigel: WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE FROM YOU
IS TO SORT OF CHANGE IT UP.
WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE
THAT CLASSIC BEAUTY.
TAKE OUR IMAGINATION
SOMEWHERE ELSE--A LITTLE SEXIER,
A LITTLE MORE UNUSUAL.
Eric: IT DOES HAVE, LIKE,
A HINT OF '20s, WHICH IS SORT OF
VERY CURRENT RIGHT NOW.
Stephen: I JUST
DON'T THINK IT CUTS IT.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW THAT SEXINESS
A LITTLE BIT MORE,
THAT WE DISCUSSED.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, APRIL.
April: I WANTED TO LISTEN TO
STEPHEN AND SHOW OFF THE LEGS.
Janice: IT DOESN'T LOOK
VERY "MODELY" TO ME.
I THINK IT'S THE PERFECT LOOK
FOR A NIGHTCLUB.
Eric: THERE'S JUST
TOO MUCH SKIN SHOWING.
Stephen: I AGREE WITH ERIC.
I THINK YOUR SHOWING
TOO MUCH SKIN...
Nigel: I LIKE THE UNDERWEAR.
Stephen: TOO MUCH.
YOU WOULD, NIGEL.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY, MERCEDES.
Mercedes: OKAY, I DEFINITELY
WANTED TO SHOW OFF MY SHOULDERS
AND HAVE A PLUNGING NECKLINE.
Janice: I LOVE THE FACT THAT
YOU DIDN'T TAKE IT TOO LOW...
(coughing)
I THINK IT'S "A"-PLUS.
Tyra: IT LOOKS LIKE
A DESIGNER
REALLY TOOK A LONG TIME
TO REALLY SKETCH THAT,
AND IT WAS HIS VISION.
Eric: IT REALLY
LOOKS LIKE A TOP.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
A CUT-UP T-SHIRT.
I THINK YOU'VE DONE
AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB.
Stephen: AND YOU DEFINITELY
GOTTA COME WORK WITH ME
IF YOU CAN CUT THAT WAY
THAT QUICKLY.
I TELL YOU.
Mercedes: GRAZIE.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
YOU ALL DID
SOME VERY GORGEOUS PICTURES
ON THE LAKE COMO.
AND FIRST,
I NEED SHANDI AND YOANNA
TO PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
HERE IS THE BEST PICTURE.
Stephen: WOW.
Eric: WOW.
Nigel: REALLY GREAT.
YOU GUYS LOOK FANTASTIC.
VERY HELMUT NEWTON-ESQUE.
Janice: THIS IS
A SERIOUS GIRL-ON-GIRL SHOT.
Tyra: I LIKE THE SHOT,
'CAUSE SHANDI'S THOUGHT OF
AS SO THIN AND SO FRAIL,
AND SHE'S SHOWIN'
A LITTLE PA-DOW!
MAYBE YOU CAN DO SOME
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
OR SOME VICTORIA'S SECRET
WERE YOU CAN MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
AND NOT JUST BE
A POOR FASHION GIRL.
Janice: YOANNA,
YOU LOOK FANTASTIC HERE.
Tyra: CAN WE SEE A CLOSE-UP?
Eric: IT'S AMAZING
TO SEE THAT YOU CAN BE
REALLY VERSATILE.
Janice: SHANDI, YOUR FACE
KIND OF LOOKS A BIT PAINED HERE.
Stephen: SHANDI,
YOUR LEGS ROCK IN THIS PICTURE.
Nigel: BUT YOUR FACE
DOESN'T QUITE WORK,
AS MUCH AS I LIKE YOANNA'S
IN THIS PARTICULAR SHOT.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
APRIL AND MERCEDES,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Eric: WOW.
Nigel: YOU LOOK LIKE SISTERS
IN THIS PICTURE.
THAT'S GREAT.
IT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
TO THE OTHER GIRLS' SHOT.
IT'S MUCH SOFTER.
Eric: 'CAUSE THIS IS
MORE ABOUT THE WOMANLY CURVES
OF A WOMAN'S BODY.
Janice: THIS PHOTOGRAPH
ABSOLUTELY COULD BE
FOR ANY PERFUME AD.
Nigel: YOU KNOW,
WHEN I FIRST SHOT YOU,
YOU WERE SEXY AND YOU HAD
A GREAT--A LOT OF SEX APPEAL.
AND SINCE THEN,
I'VE STOPPED SAYING THAT.
AND I'M SAYING,
"WHERE DID THAT SEX APPEAL GO?"
AND HERE YOU ARE AGAIN NUDE,
AND YOU BROUGHT BACK
THAT SEX APPEAL. YOU NEED TO
REMEMBER THIS--
Tyra: THERE'S ALSO TWO DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SEXY--
THERE'S "MAXIM," "FHM,"
"STUFF" SEXY,
AND THEN THERE'S HIGH
FASHION SEXY.
AND THIS IS WAY MORE
HIGH FASHION SEXY.
JAY FELT THAT YOU TRIED
TO CONTROL THE SHOOT,
AND THAT YOU OVERDIRECTED IT.
Mercedes: NO.
April: I WAS
TALKING A LOT TO MERCEDES.
Mercedes: I THOUGHT,
LIKE, WE WORKED WELL,
AND SO SHE WAS LIKE,
"OH, IF YOU PUT IT HERE
MAYBE..." AND THEN I'M LIKE,
"YEAH, YOU KNOW, THAT WORKS."
Janice: SOMETIMES
IT'S REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT
NOT TO OVERSTEP YOUR BOUNDARIES
WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHER,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
Tyra: THANKS, LADIES.
Tyra: YOANNA.
Janice: YOANNA
CERTAINLY AMAZES ME.
SHE'S GOT ROLLS OF SKIN
THAT HANG OVER HER JEANS.
AND IN THIS NUDE,
I DON'T SEE IT.
Nigel: SHE LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S GOT A BUTT,
WHICH IS A MIRACLE,
'CAUSE QUITE FRANKLY,
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT BEFORE.
Tyra: I THINK
IT'S THAT SHE'S A GOOD MODEL,
AND SHE KNOWS HOW TO POSE.
SHANDI.
Janice: HER LEGS ARE AMAZING.
SHE'S REALLY FALLING INTO
A TOP-MODEL LOOK.
Nigel: SHANDI REALLY IS
THE WILD CARD.
SHE'S COME FROM BEING
THIS WALGREENS GIRL
TO THIS EXTRAORDINARY SORT OF
HELMUT NEWTON-ESQUE LADY
IN THIS PICTURE.
MY PROBLEM WITH SHANDI
IS HER ABILITY
AT BEING A SPOKESPERSON.
Eric: FOR ME,
SHANDI SEEMS LIKE A FOLLOWER,
NOT A LEADER.
Stephen: I THINK
THIS GIRL HAS HUGE POTENTIAL.
I THINK THAT SHE HAS TO GROW
INTO HERSELF AND UNDERSTAND
THE INDUSTRY BETTER.
Tyra: IT'S JUST,
IT'S SO DIFFERENT FROM
THE GIRL THAT WAS, YOU KNOW,
IN GLASSES ALL THE TIME
AND JUST GOT CONTACTS
AND DIDN'T REALLY KNOW HOW
TO FOCUS WITHOUT HER GLASSES ON.
NOW SHE'S TOTALLY CONNECTING.
APRIL.
Eric: HERE SHE'S DOING
AN ADVERTISEMENT
FOR, LIKE, MUMMIES,
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S NO LIFE IN HER.
Janice: TONIGHT, THE WAY
SHE CHOPPED UP THE T-SHIRT,
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN, YOU KNOW,
THE QUEEN OF THE DISCO.
Stephen: SHE THINKS TOO MUCH.
SHE'S TRYING TO DEPICT A MODEL
HOW SHE'S SEEN IT
IN A MOVIE OR SOMETHING.
Nigel: I THINK APRIL,
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS,
HAS GONE FROM STRENGTH
TO STRENGTH.
Tyra: YOU JUST LIKE THAT ASS.
Nigel: I DO.
Tyra: MERCEDES.
Stephen: WELL,
IN THIS PICTURE,
SHE JUST REFLECTS EROTIC TO ME.
I THINK SHE HAS
ONE FAULT, THOUGH.
I THINK SHE'S GOT
REALLY SHORT LEGS.
Tyra: MERCEDES SHOCKS ME
FROM WEEK TO WEEK TO WEEK.
SHE USUALLY LOOKS LIKE
STRAIGHT OFF THE MALL.
FINALLY SHE CAME IN HERE
LOOKING MORE HIGH FASHION.
Janice: YOU KNOW
HOW I FEEL ABOUT MERCEDES.
I WANT TO SEE HER ON THE PAGES
OF "JANE", "VOGUE"
AND THE OTHER MAGAZINES.
Nigel: MY PROBLEM IS
AS A SPOKESPERSON,
SHE'S REALLY GOOD,
AND IN YOUR MUSIC VIDEO
SHE WAS REALLY GOOD,
BUT THE FASHION INDUSTRY'S
NOT GONNA GET IT.
Janice: YOU'RE CRAZY, NIGEL.
♪♪♪
Tyra: THERE ARE FOUR GIRLS
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME--
FOUR BEAUTIFUL GIRLS--
BUT I ONLY HAVE THREE PICTURES
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE THREE PICTURES
REPRESENT THE THREE OF YOU THAT
WILL CONTINUE ON YOUR JOURNEY
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOANNA.
IN THIS PICTURE,
YOU ARE SO BEAUTIFUL,
SO EROTIC,
THE EPITOME OF ITALIAN SEXINESS.
BUT THERE'S A SEX APPEAL
IN PERSON THAT THE JUDGES
DON'T FEEL YOU HAVE
THAT YOU REALLY NEED TO WORK ON.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Yoanna: THANKS.
Tyra: YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SHANDI.
SHANDI,
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT YOU IS THAT
YOU GIVE HOPE TO YOUNG GIRLS
THAT ARE HIDING BEHIND GLASSES
THAT PEOPLE MAY BE
CALLING HER A "GEEK,"
MAY BE CALLING HER "NERDY,"
AND SHE MAY BE THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL GIRL IN THE WORLD.
AND YOU,
RIGHT NOW STANDING HERE,
YOU ARE TELLING HER
THAT SHE IS BEAUTIFUL.
WHAT WE'RE WONDERING--
DOES SHE REALLY WANT THIS,
OR IS SHE JUST HERE
ALONG FOR THE RIDE?
I WANT THE GIRL
THAT WINS THIS COMPETITION
TO RULE THE WORLD
WITH A SMILE ON HER FACE,
LIKE, "GOD, I WANTED THIS,
AND I BEAT EVERYONE."
CONGRATULATIONS.
Tyra: WILL MERCEDES AND APRIL
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS ONE PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NAME THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO YOUR ITALIAN APARTMENT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
MERCEDES, THIS IS THE FIRST DAY
THAT THE JUDGES SAW YOU ACTUALLY
LOOKING MORE HIGH FASHION
AND LESS COMMERCIAL.
THE JUDGES THINK MAYBE SHE IS
A LITTLE COMMERCIAL, AND MAYBE
CUTTIN' UP THAT SHIRT SHOWED US
A LITTLE SOMETHING ELSE,
BUT WE'RE NOT SURE YET.
APRIL, IN YOUR PICTURES,
WE FEEL LIKE YOU POSED BETTER
THAN ALL THE GIRLS HERE.
BUT MODELING ISN'T ABOUT
BEING MECHANICAL.
IT'S ABOUT
EMOTIONALLY CONNECTING
WITH THE CAMERA.
Tyra: MERCEDES,
CONGRATULATIONS.
April: (mouths) THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
April: (crying)
IT HURTS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I ALWAYS WIN EVERYTHING.
I'M NOT PREPARED.
I'M NOT MENTALLY PREPARED
FOR THIS.
I'M REALLY SHOCKED.
EVERY MOMENT THAT I SPENT HERE
NOT IN FRONT OF THAT CAMERA,
ALL I WAS DOING WAS WAITING
TO GET BACK IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA.
BUT I CAN'T GO BACK
TO DOING WHAT I WAS DOING.
IT WAS KILLING ME.
I CAN'T GO BACK THERE.
I'M GONNA BE A TOP MODEL ANYWAY,
'CAUSE IT'S MY CALLING.
AND I'LL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
I GUESS THAT THIS
IS JUST NOT MY WAY.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM THE SEASON FINALE.
Tyra: HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP
ON THE SEASON FINALE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
AFTER NINE DIFFICULT CUTS,
ONLY SHANDI, YOANNA
AND MERCEDES ARE LEFT STANDING.
OUR FINALISTS ARE FACED
WITH THE ULTIMATE CHALLENGE,
AND OUR JUDGES ARE LEFT
WITH THE ULTIMATE DECISION--
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
Eric: THIS REALLY IS HARD.
Janice: IT'S REALLY HARD.
MY HEAD... UGH.
♪♪♪